grant
is with us in nashville to start off
this hour hey brent how are you
i'm doing well sir how are you better
than i deserve what's up
well um i was calling because i just
recently moved to tennessee
for a girl and she and i've been getting
very close
and we started looking at rings
i've got about 1500 in the savings
account for my
step one i'm working on step two um
about to finish paying off credit cards
the only payment i have left
is um io on my pickup that i drive
and um i was starting to think about
buying a ring and popping the questions
so i was wondering if i
should pause on the debt after i pay off
the credit card
pause on the pause on overpaying the
truck and try to
save up money for the wedding and
honeymoon and all that or
if you think that would be a bad idea
well i think you're going to get married
and i think and i think you better
figure out a way to pay for it so yeah
i mean i don't think there's you know
any questions so you're probably pushing
pause
on your whole baby steps thing right now
and piling up cash cash uh first for a
ring
um and then you know once you set a date
then you lay out your goals to and what
you need to spend on a wedding so what
do you make
um currently i'm making around 35
to 4 000 a month okay all right
and what would you i mean have you had
any discussions with her at all that
this is not a surprise to her or you
guys have talked about the type of
wedding or how far out this might be
she finds out by listening right now i
hope that's how she pulls out yeah
um well we've we've gone out together
and looked at rings
and she just picked one out uh it's kind
of well we she didn't
we haven't bought it or anything yet but
she definitely i saw the way she looked
at it so i'm kind of like that's the
ring i got to get you know at this point
maybe
maybe a little bit more than what i was
thinking but how much it's a really
pretty rain
um i believe it was three thousand
okay that's all right one month one
month's income is your max on a ring
yeah so three will do and you save up
obviously and you pay cash for it
um then then you start talking about
okay what are we going to spend on the
wedding and how far away is that
and you know can we save up that amount
of money during that time if you can't
then that's not your wedding budget
yeah so any idea how long this might be
um i don't know to be honest it's kind
of one of those things
we actually just met back in a january
um crazy story um i didn't
ever think we would be here but here we
are um
and so we really agree on a lot and
she's actually the one that's kind of
been pushing me to start
studying your process and and your
systems
and i actually just started listening to
you yesterday
and it was kind of like uh almost like
drugs for me i started and i just i
started listening to every
every podcast that would come on these
are good drugs
just to clarify drugs that'll help you
it's an antibiotic i mean it's kind of
one of those things where she and her
mom
they have very they've told me a little
bit about your system and things like
that and so i kind of
yesterday i everything's just kind of
becoming a little more real so i just
decided
you know i want to make sure that i can
give her a good future and
and my family a good future so i started
listening to you and
and it's kind of just one thing's led to
another work
um currently she does work um
she is uh she said she plans to work she
wants to be a homemaker and i love that
about her
um that's wonderful how much debt does
she have
uh she has none okay and what does she
current what does she currently make
um she i don't know the specifics uh i
know
her parents gonna pay for the wedding i
am not sure on that either i i'm
thinking so
um they're very traditional and so i'm
thinking
that you know there's going to be quite
a bit of an offset cost that they're
going to take care of
okay on that part how old are you guys
i'm 25 she is 20. okay yeah i suspect
all right cool that's fine well i i
think that the first thing is
you say yes we're going to push pause
and yes we buy a ring
and no you don't do not pay more than
one month's income the jewelry stores
sometimes will tell you up to three
months
income for an engagement ring and here's
the thing i'm a real practical guy i get
it that you're in love
but i'm a real practical guy and there
is zero correlation between the size of
the ring and the success of the marriage
as a matter of fact at this point the
ring gets to a certain size there's an
inverse correlation
so um meaning that a huge ring can
indicate failure yeah
yeah if she well and she's the type that
she would be fine with a 200
ring i know but she picked out a three
thousand dollar ring and smiled
yeah oh there it is there it is so
yeah so she's obviously a great gal so
you stop and you save up for the ring
um then when you but you have to then
um assess what responsibility you guys
have for the wedding and the honeymoon
and you have to say and you have to say
that has to be far enough out that you
can save up and pay cash for that too
yeah and i know it's not going to be
something where we're getting married
next month or anything like that no but
you
so let's just say let's just pick a
number okay let's say
next may all right and um
you know and so you know you have what
uh ten months or something okay and uh
and you're gonna need ten thousand
dollars well you need to save a thousand
dollars a month
or you need to get ten thousand dollars
before you push play again
on your baby steps so we're going to get
the ring
and your your portion of the wedding
that you're going to pay cash for
out of the way before you push play
again and get it start getting out of
debt does that make sense
yeah yeah and i know she's she's kind of
ma
she's a lot better with money than i am
clearly
just because she put she did put me on
your trail i
used to be really good with money and
then i got a job making a lot of money
and i suddenly got very bad with money
you know it it's kind of one of those
things you the more you make the more
you spend
yeah i think you're gonna be okay i
think it's gonna work out
and um yeah we we will continue to be
the antibodies
antibiotics the good drugs to help you
guys get this dialed in but yeah
nothing you told me here is out of line
if you come in and go we're going to
finance a 30 000
wedding because that's her dream wedding
then i'm going to say whoa you start
telling me you're gonna buy ten thousand
dollar ring on thirty thousand on three
thousand dollar four thousand a month
income i'm gonna say whoa
uh i'm you know i've always wanted to go
to the caribbean and drop
or go to hawaii and drop ten grand on my
honeymoon whoa
uh not with the numbers you're giving me
here so uh not unless you're getting
married five years from now which is
also whoa so um
you know you just gotta you gotta dial
in use some common sense and some
planning some goal setting and then
that'll tell you what your
points are that you have to hit and what
you know the level of wedding you're
going to have
and that's all part of the program